Hello everybody my name is Markiplier and welcome back to Subnautica! Now we're going to be doing A LOT today
We need to build a nuclear reactor! And kiss our ass goodbye when we jump into this giant pit!
But thank you to Karley Arlington, who said the terrifying suggestion that there might be a giant monster
Gaping with its mouth wide open *laughs* for me to jump into it when we go down there. Which is terrible to think about, but thank you!
And then DevilNinja who said that the bed... if I wanted to find, there's actually a bed that you can sleep in, in the game and it can pass time.
That's found in the JellyShroom caves. So those are the purplish caves that I can go down in. I BELIEVE that there's an abandoned base in there somewhere.
And then WonderHuman, who reminded me, that if I jump down, I won't be able to get back out. So I need to find a way to do that.
But I don't think I'm gonna do that, I think I'm gonna just jump and then THAT'S GONNA BE THE END FOR ME!
And then that's not "LightningShit" that's "LightningShot" who suggested that I don't take the, uh, the, the, the, the, the, the, THE, THE, THE,
The diving suit, whatever the diving suit is- don't take it above water, it will crash my game. So thank you for that and thank you guys.
And the first thing that we're gonna do is, I'm going to build the nuclear reactor because I have all the materials that I need right here
And it's right here "hoooooo" let's keep the... panel right here at the beginning and then once I get this up in order,
It needs uranium which is processed from those "uranininite" crystals that  got before. So if I look at this, it needs uranium I believe
If I put- Oh Shit... WELP... THAT... HUAHHH THAT DOESN'T SEEM TO BE WORKING, HUH?
It doesn't take the "Uraninite" Crystals, I think it needs to be...
"You can only add reactor rods to the nuclear reactor."
Well HOWDY FUCK ME that ain't good enough for what I'm doing.
But either way, I'll figure out how to do that in just a second, but what you're doing in here,
you take the "uranininite" crystals and you turn them into URANIUM
And then I'm assuming somewhere in here...
Reactor Rod!
Ahh! I need lead! Do I have lead down here? Please tell me I have lead down here. If I don't have lead down here I'm gonna be
SOO PISSED, god dammit
I don't wanna keep cheating on you guys, but some things need to be done!
I'm sorry! I'm a- dah, ah, god damn it! Ahhh! I'm a dirty dirty cheater. I'm sorry I need lead.
I can't get anything. It takes me so long to bring materials and I thought I had
everything that I needed to do. I
apologize, but I wanna make sure you
guys can actually see these things in a
timely fashion and save me from all day
going back and forth in between the surface and here. Which is hard enough as it is.
I have titanium, I do have that! *High Pitched scream*
*majestic singing*
Aaaaand... SCHWABOOSKI!
Okay, so we got that, we got the rods, now we just need to shove our rod in this machine
and it'll give us oh-so-much
power.
Wahbam! I don't know how much power. Ahhhhh it seems to be going up at a good clip.
Wow, actually that's going up at a decent clip. Considering that the EIGHT bioreactors
that I had going on, was gaving me, was giving me maybe one power every two to three seconds?
This is givin' me a good amount of power. This is doing more than those EIGHT bioreactors.
So, it may not have a lot of flash, it may not be spinning and zapping.
I was hoping it was gonna be doing that, but this is working!
It's good, HOORAY! We got a nuclear reactor! Okay, so that's besides the point.
Because the next thing that we need to do, we need to upgrade the, uh, we need to upgrade
the, uh, pressure compensators.
Whoopsie-doopsie. Yeah, no, they were there. Oh no I got 'em in my- and you upgrade
'em at the modification station. So, in the seamoth upgrade, you upgrade them to
pressure compensator MK2, and then you take that one and you upgrade it to pressure
compensator MK3. Now this takes A LOT of material.
Oodles and oodles of material. You need a total for just one MK3:
5 plasteel ingots, which takes 5 titanium ingots, mixed with... was it lithium?
Ahh, my ear. Ah, god that was so weird. I think my ear just like- I think, you know
every once in a while you get like a high-pitched ringing in your ears for no reason?
I thought it was coming from the game, but it just faded away. Must've been from my ear.
I have no idea, that was weird. Anyway, sorry about that. But you need five plasteel ingots,
and a total of two aluminum oxide crystals and a computer chip.
This is a lot. And if I was on the surface, yes, totally. I would go get this material by myself.
But I'm 900 feet below- meters...
I'm nine hundred meters below! I'm about 3,000 feet below the surface! It's pretty far.
Okay, but we do have what we need now.
So, I'm gonna make a pressure compensator MK1, and then I'm gonna make
a pressure compensator MK2, and then I have exactly-
Don't mind my giant fan in front of me that I'm holding like my dick here...
But I have a pressure compensator MK3, which I- if I go out here to my little excavator right here,
who looks oh-so-delightful,
I'm very happy about him.
D- Oh... Wait, did they...? Wait, did they push out an update? 'Cause these guys look different!
Wait a minute! They pushed an update! Wait these guys are different!
Wait a minute! That panel was not fully fleshed out before!
Oh neb NAH! AGH! NO! Get back here. Where'd It go!?
Oh! Oh oh oh! No no no no! Oh god, I need you. Don't drop *laughs* on me! Don't drop on me.
Okay, it's fine.
Okay so, boink. Ah, crush depth now seventeen hundred meters. *Metal crushing sound*
Eugh, stop that. Okay, but 1,700 meters.
That's pretty damn deep! That is... pretty damn deep! So, what I'm gonna do...
*Clicks tongue* It's time to go into the deep! It's time to literally (Base: Welcome aboard, Captain) jump off, into nowhere...
Into the black nothingness that is down below there...
And explore the deep.
Now this is the only way to get this deep as far as I know, because the Cyclops can't go down there,
the Seamoth certainly can't go
down there, or maybe it can?
So the MK3- So the Seamoth cannot go down. The only way that it can survive down here
is because this is the old school...
This is the old school pressure compensator that allows it to go to a thousand meters.
Which is not good enough for me! So, enough stalling it's time to go down!
Waaaaay down!
I probably should bring like, you know, an extra power cell with me. But I'm not gonna do that.
Computer Voice: Welcome aboard, Captain.
Whooo boy.
Ho! Wait, whoa, hey! Ha ha!
Wait, what is that? Supposedly you're
supposed to be able to get- Yeah!
Oh! You're supposed to be able to get
materials out of like, very deep... things.
Okay. Wow. Phew. Are you ready guys? Cuz' this is it! Once I go down there,
I literally don't have a way of
coming back!
I really hope I spawn at this particular
base. Hang on, before I go I need to get one more thing.
It's not gonna help, but it's gonna
make me feel better.
Repulsion cannon. Because...
I don't know if there's gonna be anything down there, I highly doubt there's any monsters down there.
But just in case, I'm not gonna be fucking around!
Okay.
Oooh! AH AH! Oh, fuck, goddamit.
I'm sorry, I'm sorry I thought I was, *laugh/cry babbling* I was like sliding into it, oh man.
Oh, that was scary. Okay.
Enough stalling, let's go down.
Phew, okay, away we go.
Oh.
Oh, woah, what was that? Oh, still falling.
O-okay! We've hit bottom!
There's a lot of lava flow! We've only
reached 1100 meters, but it looks like
there might be further down over this
way! Oh god.
Okay, there seem to be a bunch of lava flows down here.
Nothing to be seen thus far. Seems
relatively normal.
'Cept, you know, the horrible... implications of a giant... underground river of lava.
Oh, and it's st-, oh.
I don't want to fall in that!
That probably would kill me and end my adventure very shortly.
Oh.
Man, what am I looking at?
Okay so, navigating this terrain is going to be a bit treacherous,
but I'm gonna have to go down there eventually.
'Cause it seems like this just goes up.
And remember the exosuit- that was the name of it! The Exosuit has like a jet-
Which helps you navigate around, considering it only falls downwards. Man.
This is some serious lava flow down here. Now the last time I was down here
this was not fleshed out. This did not
have terrain like this.
Maybe towards the very, very bottom of it, it had terrain like this? But I wasn't
even able to reach that. Because with the old Seamoth depth it can only go to a
thousand meters and everywhere else I had to go, like- I had to get out of the
seamoth and literally dive down.
And man, this, this light isn't doing a whole lot. But it's doing enough.
What is- oh my god, there's resources down here! Thank goodness! Let me see if I can get this
with my new hammer fist. Eh! Eh! Eh!
Eh, shit, where am I? Aw, shit, where'd I go? There you are. C'mon.
Pow! Pow! Pow!
Okay, I'm gonna hop out for a second here.
What is this.
Ooo!
Hey! Diamond! Cool!
Alright! So this is probably the only place to get diamond.
Which is probably gonna be a risk/reward thing. I bet diamond is used for some like advanced recipes.
If not now, then definitely in the future. But I bet it's gonna be dangerous to come out here.
Not only because of the crushing depth, but also because of the monsters that might lurk in the dark.
If you know what I mean.
Okay, so we seem to still be going down.
I don't know if there's a point that reaches max- *sharp inhale*
Fuck, god damn it, stop that. I'm on edge. Jesus.
Gettin' down. Whoa, whoa, whoa! You guys seeing what I'm seeing?!
What it- WOAH WHAT IS THAT?
HOLY SHIT! What have I found?!
WOAH! WOAH NELLY!
HI! WHAT IS THAT?!
Whoa, what is that?
I don't know what that is! Woah god damn- Oh! I think I remember that!
Wait a minute! When I came down here before, this wasn't all fleshed out.
But, when I came down here before, I remember there being these tall spires.
And I tried to go to the base of them, and I believe I'm down near them now.
Oh my god, what is that? Oh, it's gone now.
Oh shit, gotta make sure I don't fall into a lava pool.
Woah.
That's AWEsome. That's so cool!
Woah. Oh, I thought that was a thing, okay. But that's so cool!
How did these form? I mean, I know obviously it's a video game, it formed 'cause the creators
made it this way. But god damn it, oh, it still makes me curious!
Just like the giant skeleton: it's like, how'd that get there?
I know someone d-drew it up and put it there - but god damn!
Oh, that's nuts!
Oh, that's so nuts.
You know, I uh- like, it, it's an easy comparison to make, uh, between underwater environments and space?
And what's weird, is I'm getting some vibes, like, from an alien world.
I mean, I know obviously I'm on an alien world. But I'm getting like an above water vibes of exploring
the depths of space.
Oh man, that just goes up, doesn't it? Holy shit.
Oh man, oh wow! What the- *amazed voice* Ohh my god... Oh my god... OH my god.
I'm still not on the highest one but I don't feel a need to go over there.
Alright. Wow. Okay, continuing on! I just wanted (Exosuit: Welcome aboard, captain) to take a look at that, that was nuts.
Here we go, babooski! Uh-oh.
Waaaaah!
Also, there seems to be a-
an even farther down. Like holy shit, way farther down. So you know, let's not hesitate.
Oh my god, is that-
Whoa, oh.
Oh no. Oh no! Oh no! Why did I come down here?!
Oh shit. Alright, so, this is getting even
farther down! I believe this is farther
than anything that has been here before.
It's kind of testing the limits of my ability, but there's another crevice over there!
I'm gonna... go into it.
Oh my god, it GOES FARTHER DOWN!!
Really!?
Ohhh my god.
Oh and it gets dark down here. Ooo, oooh.
That made the lava turn a weird shade
of green! Ooooh, what's happenin'?
What was that?
(hollow warbled sound)
Getting awfully noisy down here. Whoa, what is that? What am I looking at here?
*Gasps* What is that?? What is that!?
Oh my god, what is that? What is-?
Well.
I- I seem to have gotten to a place where it felt necessary to play some additional music!
It's like a river of magma! It's just that the atmosphere is so dark and dense down here.
Oh geeze that doesnt sound good. Hang on let me hop out for a second.
Woah!!
*liltingly* Oh my god. Holy shit.
Okay, let's go for it. Oh Nelly.
We're gonna play hopscotch! An extreme game of the floor is lava!
Holy shit. *grunts*
Okee. Okee.
Okee.
Wohkee.
Wow.
What the fuck.
Ohhh.
Woah ho.
Woah!
I'm, I'm so happy. I'm so happy right now. And terrified. I'm equal measures of happy and terrified
because- whoa!
Woah! Okay, music stopped. Oh Nelly. Woah Nelly!
Whoa Nelly! Whoa Nelly! Whoa Nelly Nelly.
I can't even see where there might be another possible way to go because it's so dark in here.
Oh, it's so dark.
So densely dark.
Oh boy. I'm surprised I'm not squished like a tin can the second I leave my Exosuit.
Oh, there's something over there.
It's just another lava flow, I believe.
But this must be the lowest point, considering all the lava is pooling down here.
Mmmmmust be. But I can follow the lake a little bit... down this way because it seems like it stretches
on down this yonder way. But I do believe I have found the lowest point where-
Waaaaaah oh, woah, woah, woah. Okay.
Woah, WOAH, WOAH! WHAT THE FUCK?!
WOAH THE FUCK! WHAT THE FUCK IS THAT!
...HELLO...
...HI?
HOLY SHIT! That is the creepiest thing I've ever seen!!
Wasabi one?! Why are you down here?!?
What the fuck, man??
Oh! Oh, what the fuck!
What the fuck?!
I know that's probably just like... the developers putting this down here for...
some reason?
What the fuck, man??
Oh, that's so weird!!
I didn't spawn that in! I did NOT spawn
that in! That was not me!
That was there!!
That's just down here!!!
Why?!?
Huh.
Eugh. That is, (Exosuit: Welcome aboard captain.) that is beyond creepy.
I have a funny feeling that, like - if this was a horror game, as soon as I turn around and look back,
he's gonna be standing right behind me. Oh god, that is terrifying.
Oh, that's so weird, that's so weird!
Oh man, is he like guarding the entrance to something, or...? Like horrifying like that?
No one would be able to see him!
It was just pure luck that I came across him!
Man, now I'm just afraid I'm gonna r-- woah.
Whoa, where am I?
Woah, what am-- woah, woah, WOAH, WOAH! I'm fallin'!
I'm fallin'! Where am I going?!
Oh shit!
OH SHIT! WHAT THE FUCK?!
UUUUUUUM... OKAY??
WHAAAAAAAAAT!?
Where the fuck am I??
What is this?!
What the SHIT?!
I'm just stumbling across...
the weeeeirdest shit, BRAH!
My god!
Oh my god!
What the fuck is this?
I just fell in a hole... and--
What is this??
It, it's, it's a part of it.
Someone built this.
Someone made this down here! I'm like in a fishbowl!
Is this gonna be like-- Is this like, physically-- is this like... the lair of the sea dragon, or the Sea Emperor?
Oh man.
What the shit?
Whoa, uh-oh. Uh-oh. Wait a minute. What's down there?
There's more!
Oh boy.
Okay, well...
This-this might just go beyond-- I-I found another hole but it might just go beyond my crush capacity.
At this point what can you do?
We've gone this far.
Let's save.
And jump down.
Okay! Here we go!
Oh jeez. Oh jeez.
Mistake!
Oh god!!
Oh, it was just a pit!
Oh, it was a trap!
Oh shit.
Well... Try to thrust out of here.
Prolly not gonna happen, 'cause I think the Exosuit takes way long to... die.
Eeh, climb on.
Eeh.
Whup, oh, oh, oh! Ohp, ohp, ohp, ohp.
I think I found a way!
You can kinda like glide up on the walls if you keep the thruster going.
Ooh, ooh, oop! *singing* Scoodelyboop de boop de boop!
Scoodloop boop dedoo!
*sing-songy* I'm gonna survive!
*sing-songy* Because I'm probably exploiting something in the physics.
H-hey!! *laughs* I made it out! Well damn! Look at me!
Right! I think that was the deepest point in the game!
But I survived and I made it out.
Where am I? What am I doing? Where'm I going?
Hang on, let me-- let me stay me stay down here for a little bit. I don't want to go...
I don't want to try to go back up, but it seems like there's a way I can go back up at the moment because...
There's one more thing--
I'm pretty much done for this episode. Wow, I did not expect there to be so much stuff down here.
But there's one more thing that I want to do before the end of this episode. And it's...
There's another thing that you can spawn in...
That is fully animated now...
and has accompanying terrifying sound.
Stop doing a dance. I know you're excited, but just stop dancing for a second.
Let's make a mistake!
OH FUCK! Goddamn it. Jesus.
Wait, where the fuck am I? What happened to my suit?
Oh shit. Oh god! Well, it robbed me! Oh, WHY IS MY SUIT OVER THERE?
Did it pick it up?? Oh jeez, oh hi.
Hello, how are you doing?
I am fine. Can I please get in? No, don't do that!
Can I please get in? Thank you. Okay!
Well that was-- Hiii.
Well!
Okay.
Well, I don't hear anything, so... Maybe they were lying about that but now the guy is fully an-- Hello.
Wow... Hiii! He's fully animated.
Oh, he's big. Ooh, he's a big mama-jama. Look at the size of that ffuuudger.
Well, that's okay.
I expected there to be sounds, but maybe he's aggressive. Now this is a bad idea.
Whoa, my god.
Hup!
Let's see if the repulsion cannon works on him!!
Probably doesn't! Are you stuck in something?
Whoa, hey you seem to be stuck in something.
Can I help you? Oh, he's stuck.
Let me getcha out of there.
There we go. Did I help him? Oh my god where's he going? He went into a wall.
Habooshki Habooshki Habooski heheheheheheheh...
Stasis Field?
yup yup god damn i think he bugging out because it's too deep from pulling
oh wow got your shit left him
I had him that I didn't have them hadam
but i didn't have them and have lost him
hey buddy AGH! O MY GOD! ARGHH!
I was Eatin' Oh God!
I didn't know that was possible.
I mean I figured it would be possible
hello
well god damn damn damn damn
well I suppose that's it then
well holy shit that was a thing
so anyway that is all the time I have
for subnautica thank you guys so much for
watching
I'm not going to do another video until
there's another big update obviously I
think I've gone through pretty much
everything that there is in these new
updates but I'm going to keep this all
here and ready for when the new next
update comes
so we will see that when we get to it
thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video. Buh-bye!
*Outro Music*